66% des panélistes
la refusait en 1988,
58% en 1999
et 48% en 2011.
Ah, le panel d'usagers,
l'organisme de confiance des autorités linguistes
qui fait preuve de souplesse.
J'espère que vous vous dites :
« Mais qui fait partie de ce panel ? »
Et que faire de leurs décisions ?
Dans les premières pages des American Heritage Dictionaries,
vous pouvez trouver les noms
des panélistes.
Mais qui lit les premières pages ?
Les panélistes sont environ 200.
Parmi lesquels des académiciens,
des journalistes et des écrivains.
Il y a un juge de la Cour Suprême
et quelques linguistes.
Et en 2005, moi.
(Applaudissements)
Ce que nous pouvons faire pour vous,
c'est vous donner une idée des avis
divergents sur les usages des mots.
Dans les limites de nos compétences.
Nous ne sommes pas une académie linguistique.
Une fois par an, je dois voter
pour de nouveaux usages,
de nouveaux sens ou prononciations.
Pour m'aider à décider, j'observe
ce que les gens disent et écrivent.
Je ne me base pas sur ce que j'aime
ou pas dans la langue anglaise.
Je vais être honnête :
je n'aime pas le mot « impactful ».
Mais la question n'est pas de savoir si
« impactful » fait maintenant partie du langage courant
et peut être utilisé dans toute prose.
Pour être scrupuleuse,
je dois rechercher les usages,
ce qui signifie consulter des bases
de données sur le net comme Google Books.
Et donc si vous y cherchez « impactful »,
voilà ce que vous trouverez.
Il semblerait qu'« impactful »
soit utilisé par
un certain nombre d'écrivains,
et ceci de plus en plus
depuis les 20 dernières années.
Maintenant certains des changements
qui vont se produire vont nous déplaire.
Des changements qui vous feront dire
« Vraiment ?
Faut-il que cela change comme cela ? »
Ce que je dis,
c'est que nous devrions être plus
prudents avant de condamner un changement,
avant d'imposer aux autres
nos préférences en termes de mots,
et surtout nous devons répugner à penser que la
langue anglaise est en difficulté.
Non. Elle est riche et vibrante et se
nourrit de la créativité de ses usagers.
Rétrospectivement, il est fascinant de
constater qu'un utilise « nice » pour dire « bête »
et « décimer » pour
« tuer une personne sur 10 ».
(Rires).
On trouve stupide la crainte de
Ben Franklin envers le verbe « notice ».
Eh bien, vous savez quoi ?
Nous paraîtrons un peu stupides dans 100 ans
de nous être inquiétés du verbe « impact »
et du nom « invite ».
Le langage ne change pas si vite qu'on
ne puisse pas s'adapter.
Cela ne marche pas comme cela.
Je voudrais que vous ne trouviez
pas ces changements inquiétants
mais drôles et fascinants
comme le font les éditeurs.
Je voudrais que vous mettiez votre
créativité au service du langage
et ainsi le rendiez plus fort.
Donc comment un mot entre-t-il dans le dictionnaire ?
Quand nous l'utilisons,
que nous continuons de l'utiliser,
et les éditeurs de dictionnaires observent cela.
Si vous pensez « Alors, nous décidons tous
du sens des mots ! »,
je répondrais, « oui exactement !»
et c'est comme ça depuis toujours.
Les dictionnaires sont d'une incroyable richesse
mais il n'existe pas d'autorité objective
qui puisse finalement décider du sens des mots.
Si un groupe de gens utilise un mot
et sait ce qu'il signifie, il existe.
Ce peut être un mot d'argot,
ou un terme informel,
ce peut être un mot que vous trouvez
illogique ou inutile,
mais ce mot que vous utilisez,
ce mot est réel.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)